what was your first encounter with mark
how did you first hear about his story
um I just I stumbled upon the
documentary and once I'd seen it I
couldn't get it out of my head so I
started doing some research to figure
out who had the rights to it if anyone
was doing anything more with the story
and found out that Robert Zemeckis had
optioned it and had written a script so
I contacted him I'd never met him before
so that was a little bit intimidating to
kind of throw my hat in the ring and say
hey you know I'm casting this thing
exactly so yeah so it's the first time
I've ever done that but it really it
moved me and it's stuck with me one of
the things that bob has done is bring
the stories that Mark has told to life
and Mark made his own movies and told
his own stories at the very first
conversation with Bob with Bob was it
clear that he was going to divide the
film into these imagine scenarios and
then what will describe its real life
was that always his idea that he was
going to bring those stories to life
through whatever animation techniques he
it was and and the reason the
explanation he gave was that why and I
agreed with this why just do a movie
that is the cinematic version of the
documentary it had to expand his world
in some way and so he Bob is very good
at telling his vision it's because it's
it's hard to imagine on your own what
something's going to look like but he's
so specific in in the way he lays out
the story and lays out the pictures for
you so I I I loved the idea of using his
expertise to bring that doll world to
life at what point did you meet mark was
it before you started working on the
film and we had um they had agreed to
make the film and Bob and I went to New
York to meet with him and spend some
time at his home he lives in upstate New
York
so we met there a couple of months
before we started shooting and spent
some time with him what did you take
away from those meetings what was your
impression could not have been a nicer
person he's he's very shy he's very
self-deprecating he has a great sense of
humor but I think
what struck me most was that he just
lacks any sort of cynicism which is one
of the reasons I wanted to do the movie
is that I think in our world today we're
surrounded by mostly cynical images and
thoughts and and and this was a person
completely lacking in that and and that
that moved me and struck me especially
in the face of what had happened to him
you know the victim of his hate crime
and he was able to come out the other
side and channel all of that anger and
pain into something really beautiful and
kind and productive among the many
horrible things that happened to mark is
that he didn't have a lot of insurance
and he was actually sent out of the
hospital before he was well because
whatever coverage he had was going to go
away he didn't have access to therapy he
didn't have things beyond you know the
basic things that got him going again so
how did he figure out that this was
going to be something that could help
him heal I don't know I I don't know the
answer to that I don't know how he
figured it out or whether it was just
some sort of intuitive response that he
had that he needed to keep his mind
occupied he couldn't use his hands
anymore but he needed to use his
imagination and I think and in talking
to him one of the things he said is that
he works at it every day and it's been
years since since his attack but he
works at it he challenges his brain he
knows that it the brain is a very
resilient thing and can make connections
around the connections that were
destroyed so so he challenges himself
and and forces himself to work at it and
he did it within something that he
really loved to do and was able to not
only just in terms of his dexterity in
terms of his trying to keep his mind
agile it was also a way of channeling
that that anger well creating these
scenarios in which he was this heroic
powerful figure that could get some sort
of redemption could you talk a little
bit about the physical production about
how you put the film together at what
point Bob is doing what
the animated sequences how he's using
voice actors how you yourself are
behaving in those scenes and then where
does that come in sequence to the actual
live physical production we did all of
the live-action stuff first and then
halfway through production we all got
into very tight gray jumpsuits and got
into a big room that was all green with
a lot of commotion capture stage motion
capture stage and they all sensors
picking up every everything you did and
it's the creepiest thing ever
it's though it's such a strange
experience but it was fun at the same
time because you just got to use your
imagination as he put it to me it's it's
black box theater at its most bare-bones
no there's no set there's no right you
might have steps but you don't really
have any physical problems ya know so
it's all X's on the wall and you're kind
of imagining things going on around you
but it was fun
and editorial you might have you know
additional dialogue replacement you
might come back and change things is
there any way to change a motion capture
performance or is that something that
Bob does without you and you say I don't
remember doing that or acting that way
it's like yeah I did I changed it well
that is actually one thing I said could
you make me do something that I didn't
do and he said oh yeah that's terrifying
like the thought so if I didn't smile
wide enough in a shot you could just add
more smile he's like yeah I could do
that if I felt like it but I don't think
he he did that we we did go back in and
pepper it with a couple of other shots
later on but and technically I don't
know how they how they blend that and it
how they fold it in you know that's it's
weird because we shot all this stuff on
this motion capture stage and there's
the conventional monitors and people you
know the script supervisor all of those
people but then literally behind a
curtain were another 30 people on
computers who were manipulating the
avatars of like of our doll bodies so
you could go back and watch a playback
of a very rough animation of the doll
body in the doll world to kind of get
your geography what were the most
important parts about mark that you
wanted to represent as an actor what did
you want to capture
and were some parts of that more
difficult than others first and foremost
is kindness in his generosity and his
resilience he you know after all of this
the fact that he came out the other side
and it doesn't isn't isn't bitter you
know he's he's just he's exudes this
warmth but also a sense of humor
and it was very important that his love
of shoes was a part of the movie because
that speaks to why there was a hate
crime in the first place and I think no
one wanted to take that component away
because I think it's extremely important
and the you touched on it briefly his
the the way he really idealizes women
women are and he made this very clear
women are the closest people in his life
the person who found him left for dead
was a woman you know all of that's true
all the people who nurtured him brought
him back to health continued to help him
all people he trusts most in the world
his confidence he derives great great
deal of strength and power from women
and I think that was an important aspect
of who he is because he he identifies on
on such a deep level with women and has
such a love and respect and affinity for
them that that was an important aspect
what is he doing now is he still have
this Belgian town out in his backyard he
you know what the good news is he box it
up he doesn't need it anymore he doesn't
he told us it's in boxes behind his
trailer he has other things he has other
scenarios I told I told him a story
about the first Academy Awards that I
was asked to be a presenter so I you
know my wife and I were walking the red
carpet and I stepped on a stars dress
and she screamed at me like what you
literally like oh yeah and I like
shriveled up into a little ball I was
terrified
and I told mark who it was and then
about two weeks later he started sending
me photographs of that exact scenario
and it was me on the red carpet going
and it was his star with this face like
and it really photorealistic it was
perfect
so he it's like now he's moved on to
wait did you forward that to the actress
no I yet okay now yeah keep going though
no no but but he's kid there's such a
joy in him like he takes things like
that and then he turns them into he uses
his world he uses his imagination and I
got a call from him when that first
trailer came out and he left a very
cryptic message and said hi Steve it's
mark call me and I thought oh [ __ ] you
know he didn't like it he doesn't like
the way this looks he doesn't like and I
got nervous cuz that that's really all I
care about
well at the end of this is that you know
he feels good about what we did and and
I called him back immediately and he
said I saw the trailer I've watched it
12 times I've cried every time and he's
like I love it and that world likes like
I would have done that if I could have
done that like that's the door that you
had leading up into the thing and he was
so excited and just was so warm about it
and again that generosity and here's the
thing too and Bob talked to him and said
they're going to be liberties take and
it's not going to be exactly you know
what you did not exactly a lot of it but
and he completely understood because
he's an artist himself and he
understands that as an artist Bob
Zemeckis was going to expand this one
side of it and turn it into something
you know through his imagination and
kind of take the ball and run with a
little bit further Steve great to see
you thanks for bringing us your films